i'm janis dean i'm brett baer i'm martha
mccallum and this is the fox news
rundown
friday august 19th 2022 i'm jessica
rosenthal
one year later and afghans are starving
the taliban's grip on the country is
strong and young girls are among those
suffering the most their future is not
right in afghanistan if changes aren't
made
they will not be able to work outside of
their home they will not be able to
pursue careers we speak with iowa
republican senator joni ernst
and lisa brady they're spreading hope
and help in more than 70 countries
already now the tim tebow foundation
wants to offer protection for human
trafficking survivors who are also
prosecution witnesses they need us to
care enough to do something about it to
build on this protection center and to
give them this this freedom so that they
they can testify
and i'm dr ben carson
i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's been one year now since the us
withdrew from afghanistan and since then
under taliban rule the economy has all
but collapsed there millions are facing
massive food shortages and according to
the un deputy special representative and
humanitarian coordinator for afghanistan
millions are even on the brink of
starvation the taliban has ordered women
to stay home and stay covered girls may
not receive secondary school education
like high school but some teenage girls
in afghanistan are actually still
getting an education i'm not going to
abandon these these students i can't
that's not in me tim stivan is the
president of the eileen murphy
foundation he's my former history
teacher and before the taliban took over
he and some of his current high school
students in san diego were doing weekly
virtual lesson plans with a school in
kabul many of the students were girls
and still are steivin says he was in
touch with the afghan teacher when the
taliban came in and ordered the school
closed but the teacher argued back it's
a private school so it can remain open
steivin is now the sole fundraiser for
that school we are staying up until
10 30 p.m almost until 11 o'clock to
stay with these girls because
we can see how much they enjoy us being
there for them the students i'm seeing
there's no anger at the united states
there's appreciation there is a desire
to continue this relationship they
they don't want to be abandoned and i
will not abandon them but stivan who
also works with task force argo which
helps get certain people out of
afghanistan through a vetting process
says the u.s has abandoned some afghans
who fought alongside u.s forces they
need to create pathway for deserving
afghans to leave the country full stop
he is in touch with a handful of
students and families who desperately
want to leave but can't still he says he
wants lawmakers to pressure the state
department to fast track the creation of
a family reunification portal
one year later what are lawmakers doing
and what are their biggest concerns out
of afghanistan now what we have
witnessed over the last year after the
botched withdrawal from american forces
out of afghanistan
under president biden are promises made
promises broken iowa republican senator
joni ernst one of the promises that had
been made was to hold the taliban
accountable for the rights of women and
girls and the taliban has unraveled all
of these hard-fought gains that women
and girls had seen over
the last several decades during the
global war on terrorism and biden played
with that diplomatic recognition of the
taliban and potential coordination
with u.s intelligence and
and this worked with the taliban
despite the actions of the taliban
really stripping away a number of those
rights for women and girls so that is a
serious concern of mine the president
also promised to avenge the deaths of 13
service members that were killed at the
abbey gate
and we haven't conducted any
counterterrorism strikes against isis k
in afghanistan period those deaths have
not been avenged
and then there was the promise to keep
troops in afghanistan until all
americans who wanted to leave were
evacuated
and we still have americans in
afghanistan
and so there are a lot of promises made
by this administration they have not
been kept
i don't know if you saw that our
correspondent trey yingst has been in
afghanistan he has footage from this
month of babies in medical care hospital
units and they are on the brink of death
from malnutrition
it is almost impossible to watch these
babies and toddlers lying there listless
um did did our leaving do this
and what do we do now as millions face
hunger there
our leaving
really did destabilize
afghanistan
and we know with the taliban in control
they do control
all of the supplies the food the medical
supplies throughout afghanistan
and because they are not living up to
their obligations
there are many nations that are not
providing humanitarian support or if
they are providing humanitarian support
the taliban is taking that and dictating
where it will go right so yes um the
withdrawal did enable the taliban to
control the country it did destabilize
it and we know that there are other
terrorist organizations that are still
in afghanistan and they are still
reconstituting
the taliban has said that our killing of
ayman al-zawahi earlier this month was
unacceptable and a violation of the doha
agreement as you know obviously we felt
salahiri's very presence in afghanistan
was the violation
a couple of things on that front
does
killing
al zwari mean
our so-called over-the-horizon
capabilities that we were told we had by
president biden do exist and do work
we know that over the horizon can work
and this was a clear demonstration of
that
and
we heard from president biden that al
qaeda was no longer in afghanistan
when our troops pulled out we know for a
fact that wasn't true because of
alzheimer's
killing
but that also shows us that the taliban
was coordinating
with al qaeda
because this leader was not hiding in a
cave in remote afghanistan he was
downtown kabul drinking coffee on his
veranda
you know in broad daylight
and so i would say the taliban is
actually the group that is and
they are going against the doha
agreement
so i think there is obviously some
disagreement there
over the horizon can work
if we choose to employ it and and i
don't even know if this is public
knowledge i haven't really been able to
to nail this down so i'll ask you
where are we able to stage from if we're
doing these over the horizon strikes is
it uzbekistan tajikistan i i'm still a
little bit lost where where we are is
that is that public knowledge
well we we are staging in other
countries and
what i could say
probably publicly is that the flight
hours do
take a considerable amount of time
and so there is a very small window when
you have a window of opportunity to
strike a target a very small window of
time when you can actually conduct that
strike
and then have that
apparatus return back to its staging
location
so
there are great distances that are being
covered by these drones by the unmanned
aerial vehicles
and it's not as efficient as we would
like it most certainly we can do better
but
i can tell you that having this type of
over the horizon capability well we know
it works and it will work if you choose
to conduct it it's still not as
efficient or as reliable
without
having human intelligence on the ground
or
american forces that can help guide some
of those strikes yeah of course
let's talk about the finances because i
know you've commented on it we still do
have half of that seven billion dollars
in frozen afghan central bank funds i
know the other half was given to the
families of 9 11 victims but it seems
like the prevailing thought in the
administration is that releasing these
funds is just too risky
that the central bank in afghanistan
cannot guarantee that this money
wouldn't fall into the hands of the
taliban or maybe even other terrorist
groups i know the state department has
said they're trying to find a way to
still get this money to
the afghan people
but if you don't have an organization
that can dole it out and spend it like
on the economy
then
what's the answer here with with this
money
you are absolutely correct jessica
there is about three and a half billion
dollars that remains frozen
and
trying to figure out a way to provide
those dollars back into afghanistan
without enriching the taliban
and having the taliban direct where that
money will go
is very difficult and when we don't have
that coordination in afghanistan where
we don't have eyes on what those funds
would be used to purchase what area that
we'll go into it's really hard um i do
know that there has been some pushback
as well in
the president releasing
the rest of the money to the families of
9 11 victims
there has been some pushback whether
they believe
that money should come to them or not
there's disagreement there many of the
families don't feel that they should be
taking money from the people of
afghanistan
to
go into their their own accounts
so
it's a mess
the president again has you know toyed
with different ideas
and is getting a lot of pushback so we
need to find a way to assist the people
of afghanistan make sure that they are
getting the humanitarian relief they
need
without going through the taliban
is that is that even possible you need
like a third party right i mean who what
kind of third party would the taliban
allow to operate
that is the question of the day and
whether it is going through
non-governmental organizations
or
through organizations like the united
nations in the world food bank
programs like that can play an important
role
as long as they are able to do their
operations without interference from the
taliban
senator i told you about the work my
former history teacher tim stivan is
doing he wants lawmakers to pressure the
state department to come up with a
faster way to vet and bring in those
afghans who may be deserving of coming
here
and for a family reunification portal
are those things possible would that
even be of interest i know there may be
some security concerns in some cases and
bringing people over and i know you'd
also mentioned there's still a focus on
even just getting u.s citizens and green
card holders out as well
i think they they are
possible
as long as you do have cooperation
again from the taliban
so
if there are still those that worked for
american forces that are residing within
afghanistan
trying to get them out of afghanistan
could be a problem if the taliban is not
in agreement
and so once again the taliban is
controlling who enters and who exits
afghanistan the portal is a wonderful
idea and the reunification of those
families would be very very important
and i just want to
say that yes these things are possible
but it will take a lot of involvement
not just from congress
but from our president of the united
states who has made many promises
and has not followed through with a
single one of them
so i i just give
incredible kudos to your former teacher
and the fact that he cares enough
to really support these girls in
afghanistan and to assist them that with
their their learning so maybe they can
go on to higher education
but their future is not right in
afghanistan if changes aren't made
they will not be able to work outside of
their home they will not be able to
pursue careers
the taliban starts recognizing the
rights of women and girls in afghanistan
senator joni ernst thank you so much for
your time
absolutely thank you jessica
this is dr ben carson with your fox news
commentary coming up
what was once a discreet effort to help
human trafficking victims has become a
core mission of the tim tebow foundation
a few years ago we deepened our fight in
this terrible evil in the world of human
trafficking and child exploitation the
former nfl quarterback's non-profit
group has in partnership with other
ministries helped to rescue thousands in
the u.s and around the world but now
they're making a more specific appeal to
help a certain group of trafficking
survivors who need protection it's the
evolution of their anti-human
trafficking efforts one of the group's
four focus areas it was um
about a decade ago when my dad gave me a
call and he was preaching at underground
pastors conference and he was leading
these pastors in a country that
where faith is not allowed tim tebow
who's also a former pro baseball player
and best-selling author is the founder
and chairman of the tim tebow foundation
where he was at
there were
girls brought in to be sold and
his heart was moved and one of the
reasons why he is one of my biggest
heroes is my dad's not someone that that
turns and looks the other way and so
he took out all the money in his wallet
and he purchased the freedom of these
four young girls for 1250 dollars and he
gave me a call
and when he told me i knew my eyes were
opened and my heart was pricked to do
something and not long after i had the
chance to to go to that location and my
heart was
was grieved even more
and i just knew this was an area that we
were called to i've just been constantly
um wrecked by
the more that we've been diving in and
the more that we've been trying to help
and and build safe homes and and and be
partnered with teams of rescues and
education and and restoration the more
that um that we're impacted and the more
that we want to do and the more that
we're called to do and it's been
something that has driven us to want to
do more but i would say it's also
grieved us because
it is so
massive around the world and every now
and then um our team sometimes you feel
overwhelmed and it's daunting but then
we remember how how worthy and worth
that every single life is and to
celebrate every single one of those
lives that has been rescued and restored
and in faith hope and love has been
brought um to them it is so powerful so
in addition to
the anti-human trafficking efforts you
already have underway the education
um the safe homes
you're now working to build a shelter in
thailand with an even more specific
focus and
this pertains to certain trafficking
survivors
who have not only been rescued but are
also witnesses
for
for prosecutions how did your group
realize that that this need exists
it's uh with our partners rafa
international who we've been partners
with for quite a while and
with safe homes they got a call from the
the thai government and thai police
saying that this is needed because um
there are girls with active threats with
death threats and even prices on their
head so that they don't testify against
their trafficker and
our partners call us and it was just
something that
we knew we had to step into and so
that's why this year we made it my
birthday campaign because this
protection center is so important to the
protection of already 15 girls but
there's going to be so many more um
every week and every day um
so it is a place where for so many of
these girls who have already gone
through some of the darkest forms of
evil and they've been rescued out of it
but they still
are in so much fear and tribulation
because because they're people that are
still after them and that's why this
protection center is so important so it
can give them a home a place of refuge a
place of safety a place to ultimately
find find peace and find hope and
restoration and you know i i share with
you the stories it would also break your
heart of three-year-olds to 17 year olds
and and all the ages in between who have
gone through some of the the darkest
forms of evil and they need us to care
enough to do something about it to build
on this protection center and to give
them this this freedom so that they they
can testify and they also can find hope
and peace in the midst of that is this
something you're hoping to continue to
do in other places this specific type of
protective environment for the survivors
who are witnesses
for us it's to do whatever we can to
meet the need you know really our
mission statement is to bring faith hope
and love to those needing a brighter day
in their darkest hour of need and to
really sum that up it's a fight for
people that can't fight for themselves
and it is to fight for the most
vulnerable and
and however we can do that however we
can serve we didn't know that we would
be getting into pre you know a
protection center but you know their
lives are worth it they're worth us
adjusting they're worth us learning
they're worth us adapting to do whatever
we can um to be able to give them that
security and that freedom and that hope
your foundation also highlights the fact
that traffickers will often pursue
the survivors again even after they've
been rescued it sounds like the rescue
is never really the end of these stories
even if that even if that worst case
scenario of being pursued again you know
doesn't happen
that is absolutely correct and that's
one of our really big focuses is the the
education is so important and the rescue
is so so important to be able to bring
them to freedom it really is it is such
a peace but it's not the end it's really
near the beginning because then there
has to be love and there has to be
support and there has to be shelter and
there has to be care and there has to be
covering and all of those things and so
that's a really huge part of our heart
is not okay you're in a place and then
and we leave no it's to be able to put
around you whatever you you need to be
able to to truly find that that help
that hope and that healing
what are we just for anyone who may not
know what are the other focuses the main
focuses of your foundation and if people
donate to
timtebot.org what happens to their money
can they pick a specific focus
they can you know go to
timteofoundation.org and check it out
and
our other areas of focus
another one of those is special needs
care
it's a a big area that that god has
pricked our heart to want to serve and
and we do that in a lot of different
ways with with schools in education with
a shine on app that's a free resource to
individuals families churches
communities
also one of our biggest
special needs opportunities is something
called night to shine which is a
worldwide prom for for people with
special needs now in over 40 countries
around the world and
hundreds of locations and it's so
special because we also have hundreds of
thousands of volunteers and that's
something that that also maybe listeners
might want to get involved in find one
in their local area of their local
church their local communities and maybe
they can be a buddy or be a part of it
that's an easy way to
to be a part of it
another area of focus for us is
children with profound medical needs so
really when people are looking at it you
know though an easy way to sum it up is
if people are vulnerable if people are
hurting if people have been put down if
people are less than then those are our
people and we want to serve them we want
to love them we want to help them we
want to do whatever we can to be able to
to meet their needs and all of us can
make a difference and you know i don't
know where that is for every one of the
listeners but i know all of us we can
step up and step into the fight and make
a difference somewhere doing something
because we all have some part that we
can play well a belated happy 35th
birthday to you
because you've you've accomplished so
much already in 35 years and um d i
would just wonder do you have a project
or a goal for each birthday
like this focus on the protection house
for the human trafficking survivors
we've been um we started a few years ago
in the first one with surgeries in the
tibocure hospital and we've continued to
adapt last year was it was multiple
locations it was for uh one of the
special education schools we have in
guatemala is also for baby rescues and
in africa and there's multiple things
that we're doing so every year it's
adapted to
however best we feel like you know with
that birthday campaign we can rally and
and bring awareness to a calls but also
try to meet a desperate need that is
also very very timely you know because
so many of these needs are so urgent you
know like we were talking about there
are 15 girls that are desperately
waiting on this protection center to be
built and that's why one of our
non-negotiables is our third
non-negotiable we call it rescue mission
because a rescue mission puts a timeline
on it and and why we say that is because
we want to live on a timeline and it's
not ours but it's theirs it's every life
you know could you imagine and this is
graphic but but you know the average
girl when she is
in a form of human trafficking is that
she gets raped 5.3 times per day every
day matters that's why there's urgency
that's like why there's a timeline
well again the place where people can
find out more and to help is tim
tebow.org
tim thank you so much for your time and
thank you for all of the good that you
are doing in the world well thank you so
much for for giving me the time and let
me share and we're just we're so
grateful and uh so grateful for also so
many people that have stepped in and you
know what one thing i just want to
mention is
in this campaign over 6 000 people have
been a part of it and supported it and i
just want to say that's encouraging
because it's helped us raise a lot but i
think what's more encouraging
is that six thousand people that want to
stand on the line and you know what if
we can get more and more people that are
arm and arm you know what i really do
think that we can push back a lot of
evil together and i just think there's a
lot of great people that are willing to
to uh to stand on the line and together
we can make a big impact
many thanks to you tim tebow and lots of
luck with the ongoing campaign thank you
so much i really appreciate the time
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand fox
news radio and the fox news app download
it today rate and review the fox news
rundown on apple podcasts or wherever
you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
dr ben carson
what's on your mind our nation is in a
crisis right now
our most basic and fundamental
institutions have completely abandoned
the american people
congress spends like they have an
unlimited credit card the white house is
focused on increasing taxes and gender
equity and the media has gone completely
off the rails as they consistently lie
and provide justification for the
aforementioned insanity
however i don't think most americans
thought we would find ourselves losing
so much faith and respect for our
federal law enforcement agencies
and the department of justice
but what choice are we left with earlier
this year the department of justice
attacked parents
as domestic terrorists
for something as basic as wanting to be
involved in their kids education
the fbi propped up a two-year-long hoax
investigation on president trump over
suspected interference by russia in the
2020 election that was rooted in lies
and deception
and just last week while violent crime
steadily increases in all corners of
america we learned that the preeminent
law enforcement agency of the united
states raided a former president's home
to apparently regain classified
documents
this president campaigned on healing the
nation and restoring our unity does
anyone honestly believe that is possible
right now
the biden administration just weaponized
the justice department against his
likely future political opponent
not only is joe biden not healing the
country he's tearing it apart from the
seams and discrediting the institutions
upon which this nation was built
this is scary there's no other way to
put it never in my lifetime that i think
we would see our institutions use their
power and influence to persecute
or intimidate americans with differing
political opinions
if they can do it to the former
president
who has the means the ability and the
platform to fight back
how are the rest of the populace going
to fare
i do believe that a majority of this
country sees what's coming out of
washington and from the liberal media as
wrongdoing
i just hope we're not too late
that is why when i saw the news break
about the raid on the president's
mar-a-lago home
i called on the american people to pray
for this nation
we must return
to one nation under god
not
a nation under the totalitarian state
this is dr ben carson
chairman and founder of the american
cornerstone institute
and host of the podcast common sense
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
new from the fox news podcast network my
name is kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's kennedy saves the world
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes